for the second day in a row israeli
warplanes pound the gaza strip
missiles have flattened several homes
and apartment buildings
was having breakfast with her family of
ten when she heard neighbors calling for
the evacuation of their home and others
nearby
her home and four others were destroyed
now she and her family need to find
somewhere else to take refuge
i ran away quickly we all ran we didn't
take any clothes or belongings i took my
girls they are ill and some people had
to carry our old man on a stretcher out
of the house quickly
islamic jihad replied to the attacks
firing rockets towards israel the group
called their operation fields of unity
and say they targeted israeli towns and
military sites
according to israeli media most were
intercepted by the iron dome missile
defense system and no serious casualties
were reported
israel says it is preparing for a week
of operations
egypt and the united nations are trying
to break her truth but in the gaza strip
the human toll remains severe
israeli missiles targeted a civilian car
in the beit hanon refugee camp
um
a 73 year old who was preparing for her
son's wedding was killed in the attack
health officials say the numbers will
only rise if the fighting continues you
know now they are attacking civilians
they are attacking premises
resident areas nobody knows what will
happen in the coming few hours for that
reason this is an appeal in fact
to extend the helping hand immediately
to a ministry of helping us trip right
now and you know of course the
electricity we have shortage of
electricity it's declared now that will
be only four hours a day and 12 hours of
cut electricity this means that we will
rely in the hospitals on generators
generators will consume like half
million liters every month we do not
have this fuel right now
look at our skies this is what we're
having as nobody knows what will happen
in the coming months
the last war has caused a wide spread of
devastation here in the gaza strip a
year later almost no reconstruction has
been made the isolated coastal territory
is impoverished and the people are
hardly recovering they fear of another
round of escalation
yumnicide al jazeera gaza city